[Music]
you're suffering
they've lost
[Music]
you god protect them
gods of the universe
i come here to raise an army
today
we'll go down in history
how exciting today we'll fight
i'm gonna kill this guy
looks probably like a truthful
[Music]
this ends here and now
i'm counting on that
marvel studios thor love and thunder in
theater chill ia rated pg-13 tickets
still available
god of thunder king khan
you have finally joined our fight well
they say very late than not at all
this is very nice
as you know we used to live in a
peaceful oasis but in our gods were
murdered murdered and now our sacred
temple has been left unguarded and hope
was dissolved to control of its power it
is our most sacred shrine and it
desecrates not for long
king you can't
tell them what happened here today
third of the time that thor
the drag tag motley crew misfit
desperados turn the tide in the battle
and that's their names in history the
odds may be against us but i'll tell you
this for free here we go this
and
here and now
oh
you